قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي انه يتعين على
الجميع الكف عن الاستغلال غير المسؤول
للجيش وقادته لتحقيق مكاسب سياسيه من جهته
طالب بيني جانس الوزير في مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي او الوزير في في مجلس الحرب
طالب رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو بالاختيار بين الوحده والامن وبين
السياسه جاء ذلك في تصريحات لبيني جانز
تعليقا على سجال بين اعضاء في المجلس
الوزاري المصغر وبين رئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي هارتس هاليفي الذي شكل فريقا
للتحقيق في مجرى الحرب على غزه والاخفاق
الامني في السابع من
اكتوبر ما حدث في الامس كان هجوما نابعا
من دوافع سياسيه في خضم حرب كان من
المفترض ان يناقش الكابينه يوم امس
العمليات الاستراتيجيه التي ستؤثر على
استمرار المعركه وعلى امننا في المستقبل
لكن ذلك لم يحدث ورئيس الوزراء هو المسؤول
عن ذلك وتقع عليه مسؤوليه التصحيح
والاختيار بين الوحده والامن وبين
السياسه